dawn july 1 1946 the d-day of
operation crossroads the atomic
bomb test supervised by vice admiral
blandy at bikini at all in mid-pacific
crews leave the target ships in
bikini lagoon many for the last time
the b-29 dave's dream takes off
from crotchalane to deliver the bomb
equal to 50 000 tons of tnt while an
electric metronome counts the final second
how are your eyes
now bomb away
a deadly radioactive cloud rises over
seven miles cloud ships are tangled wrecks
the battleship nevada is towed
into position for the second test
test baker king judah of bikini watches with
admiral blandy as lst60 moves into place
the bomb is suspended beneath lst60
and is to be fired by remote control
the technicians and vice admiral parsons leave
lst 60 and the bomb at the control room crossroads
personnel are checked then locked in dr holloway
los alamos director ready's the firing circuit
seconds before age hour fifteen heroes already
aboard ship and in the sky two one fire
plutonium half the weight of a dime caused this
this system that can destroy our
world unless we find the road to peace
now
you